ce matin la tradition et annick s'est
invitée au balcon au son des trompettes
dans la cour du palais saint james
charles a été officiellement proclamé
roi
le prince charles philippe artur jorge
et maintenant par la mort de sa défunte
mère d'heureuse mémoire devenu notre
seul juste et légale s'ouvre à charles
iii cahors bat pas
camilla sont des pouces depuis 17 ans
devient reine consort
william son fils aîné prince de galles
l'aéroport d'aberdeen hier après midi il
fallait regarder sous le bandeau de la
bbc des salariés l'aéroport comprennent
en regardant leurs téléphones qui sont
en direct sur la bbc et regardez ce
qu'ils font
si riche
[Musique]
il avance devant le château de windsor
sous les vivats de la foule
brouillés depuis des mois le prince
william et son épouse kate middleton le
prince harry et son épouse meghan markle
sont venus voir les hommage à la reine
déposé devant les grilles du château
voilà des mois qu'il n'était plus
apparue tous ensemble
ils se parlent mais pas de signes
d'affection particulier qui pourrait
laisser penser à une totale
réconciliation sont des joueurs qu'ils
avaient vu ces images hier images de
communication bien sûr elle est
importante cette image de les voir
ensemble en tout cas aujourd'hui en ce
moment
comme quand les beatles la ruine les
après les 4 fantastiques
fois
les pingres
comme tous les windsor elle est très
attentif surveiller les dépenses et en
fait là elle agit comme bons nombres
d'aristocrates britannique sa classe
sociale qui sont très prospère mais qui
sont proches de leurs sous exploit
trente six heures après le décès de la
reine
des sweats commémorant l'événement à 40
euros
et des tasses à 25 euros pièce
en mémoire de la reine magnifique la
cire le responsable de la boutique à dix
fois plus de clients que d'habitude par
exemple elle est très avare sur le
chauffage très avare sur un électricité
à rennes est quelqu'un de très économe
lld pons très peu elle est connu comme
quelqu'un qui est bien fait mais la
lumière quand elle passe une pièce à un
autre ce quelqu'un qui utilise le même
vernis à ongles qui coûte 7 euros
l'étui depuis depuis 30 ans vous ne
parlez pas la reine vous n'allez pas
voir la reine c'est la dame qui est à
côté qui lui dit on va aller voir cette
personne là la reine vient alors il faut
le dire des fils et leur donnant voilà
elle vous dit vous ne parlez pas c'est à
c'est à elle de vous parler alors elle
vous dit à la dia la personne à qui j'ai
été ajouté vous trouvez pas qu'il fait
beau aujourd'hui
ah oui aimez-vous l'angleterre et hop
après vous ne l attend la réponse elle
vous regarde mais quand elle vous
regarde en fait elle se fout de la
réponse parce que son métier vous
arrivez question un débat passionnant
non plus hein s'il ne fallait retenir
qu'un seul hommage postés sur les
réseaux sociaux hier ce serait
évidemment celui d' ocean's el himer des
marseillais et oui celui ci voilà
impossible n'est pas français un océan
nelly mère a posté une photo de brigitte
macron avec marc et rip et les dates de
mort de la reine d'angleterre merci
merci france
merci fo
[Applaudissements]
jugeant qu'elle vous poser c'est à dire
que son métier ses 300 jours par an
rencontrer des gens à l'inaugurer des
pissotières ouvrir
et s'intéresser à des gens qui n'ont
rien à dire qu'il ne l'intéressent pas
elle doit elle doit leur poser une
question et s'y intéressent même le
problème c'est quoi maintenant que les
réseaux c'est que la plus droit à
l'erreur car l'ont donc moi je pensais
sincèrement en voyant reste amis que
régis c'est vrai et et les cdg même pas
lu les dates chez rip vous connaissez or
au poste voilà voilà or malgré le faste
de la couronne c'est vrai que la reine
elle n'est pas connue pour pour payer
son personnel très bien et a même eu en
2015 une grosse grève à buckingham parce
que le personnel estimé qu'il était sous
payés iphone je me souviens de mon
premier salaire à buckingham palace
c'était 990 euros pour une année une
année me donner du savon chaque semaine
dans une boîte de lessive pour laver mes
vêtements anne hidalgo qui avait reçu
elizabeth ii à paris en 2014 elle a donc
posté quelques photos d'elle avec la
reine sur twitter la maire de paris qui
à l'injuste oublier une restée fameuse à
la reine qui tient elle-même son
parapluie alors qu'anne hidalgo étaient
aidés par un assistant peut-être
devrait-il méditer cette phrase
d'abraham lincoln un homme d'état est
celui qui pense aux générations futures
un homme politique est celui qui pense
aux prochaines élections les employés du
palais sont très mal pays l'idée de la
monarchie c'est que travailler pour les
windsor apporte un tel prestige inquiet
rue que l'homme vite et qu'on n'a pas
besoin des pays